[Music]
have you guys had
a situation where someone is pretending
to be
you guys in this room online in order to
scam people
yes wow no never have to stamp people
scam
somebody's on a date with me right now
as we speak yeah
probably wait yeah virtual or however
they decided
where is where is their their preferred
platform for you instagram
they like yeah they love pretending to
be me on instagram so wait they pretend
to be you
and they write guys oh catfish and then
or women
um and they get them to send money yes
oh yeah yeah
i was on a uk dating site but i was very
flattered because they
picked a recent picture of me but they
said i was 23.
as their age nice wow that passes us out
wow
okay well compared to 21 i don't know is
that good
right true they may be an older woman
and so i was like damn 23 is like you're
grown you got your own [ __ ] your
21 is like she just wants a party people
should put me on a dating site i don't
go on a dating site no
no but most people i don't i really
wonder what people are using our photos
for dating sites because i only get
instagram notifications because people
are like
hey you wrote me or so-and-so is trying
to use your page blah blah blah blah
but i wonder like who's using our photos
on dating sites to actually
get dates i think they're trying to make
money yeah they're just trying to scam
so they'll go on a dating site and
they'll like
talk and then they'll be like a couple
months into it yeah i want to go there
but you got to pay for my flight and
this stuff
exactly the sob stories are great i've
seen the deep fakes of nikki though and
i'm like that looks like nikki sucking
dick you saw the deep freaks
dang i haven't even seen them absolute
fact
yeah they're they're deep fakes i'm like
that is another man's dick in her mouth
i'll tell you that they're fake baby
they're deep and fake
they're deep and they're so fake very
big
so deep why do you have all these deep
fakes of you on your phone
so many i collect them can you imagine
that
could you imagine dating somebody who
doesn't know what a deep fake is and you
explain it to them they're like
that's not me i would never do that it's
a deep fake
look here's the example oh i believed it
and they're really good at it now
and she's like no honey i promise you
really do have a big pp and i'm like
that guy's pb is
[ __ ] huge it's fake so fake it wasn't
real
the whole thing's fake no but yeah so
like because that's happened to me as
well
but on facebook there's been this i
think it's one person
because they continuously create a new
facebook page all the time and every
other
it's been like five years of the same
[ __ ] and people are sending me messages
like
hey what happened to you on facebook
last night we were talking and i'm like
you're being scammed you're being she
isn't there like is there a website that
like
is you it's leaky yeah i guess they're
like it's an instagram
but it's tiffany's just like hip's feet
it's just feet
wow does that mean i'm a scumbag if no
one's pretending to be me like they
don't want
i wouldn't say scumbag i'm pretty sure
you have your
your people too i think you could be a
scumbag anyways
how is it so how's somebody gonna
pretend to be bart and scam them like
what is what's his story like my son
needs diapers for you girls it makes
sense because they can try to be
a pretty girl try to scam a dude out of
money yeah i think they know that i'm so
despicable by being me
they can't scam anybody for anything so
who are they gonna scam
right like what are you maybe like hey i
showed up at barbell for my workout and
like you weren't there
if i told you that um someone's
pretending to be jason momoa
would that surprise you no because he's
a hot dude
that all chicks want to be with right
what happened are you trying to say i'm
the opposite of jason my mother no i was
actually trying to
know you you're beautiful i'm like
you're beautiful on the end you're a
[ __ ] guy
you're a buff guy with tattoos i am no
yeah so i was saying like you're a buff
dude
and jason momoa is also a buff dude are
you hitting on bart
ew no he's a fitness guru i'm a comedian
that's right that's true a new
relationship this episode are you trying
to steal our thunder right now
no we're married stop it that's weird we
are married me and tiff are married me
and tiff are married they got secretly
married in a private ceremony
surprise that's why jill's not here
today oh there's so much love in this
room you guys knew the real story dude
honestly i can't even have fun with this
joke because it's so disturbing to me
like it's [ __ ] disturbing now it's
[ __ ] up did somebody just knock on the
door
it's trying to come is she gone she
found us
she found out she has a tracker she has
a microphone on his phone
we told we were in the other office oh
she found us i'm just kidding put your
clothes back on get out of here geo
oh my god no stop put your clothes back
on dude
completely endorses this what is this
our lunch
he didn't read the note oh yeah what is
this we didn't order this
did we it smells like mexican food we
had burritos oh okay never mind sorry
take it back
you can put this in there it's fine yeah
it's actually gonna all be left in here
anyway
um we're super unprofessional oh my nail
broke
oh was that me because i accidentally
did this to you was that my fault
did you are you trying to tell me
something about my nails no because you
did this and i
did this if you know you understand the
joke
anyway jason oh
know what's up we're trying to talk
about jason momoa that's a lady joke we
could talk about you someone
if you even i know what's up he's he's a
nice man yeah
he's living here am i making you hot you
are what's happening what's the
okay wait what did he do what did he do
he didn't do anything someone's
pretending to be jason momoa to target
this
elderly woman and and so
she was trying to [ __ ] him baby i'ma
take my dentures out for you
so i've always wanted to surf and ride
your wave i don't know
what accent that was right just
right away yeah so the 72 year old
grandma
she has fallen in love with or she
believes that jason mama has fallen in
love with her
and i'm going to play this video where
they kind of she gets interviewed and
her son contacted the authorities oh
they're not going to do haka are they
it's just b-roll of the
i thought the grandma was gonna do
oaxaca to profess her love to
jason mama and he tells me he loves me
and i tell him i love him back
we're protecting the identity of this
song jackson wasn't too far off says she
communicates
deeply with jason even
[Music]
she's time a week later fifty thousand
more
wait she's one of them i'll explain in a
second
her son reached out to us for help
because he's not been able to convince
his mother
who has no cognitive impairment that
she's been conned
loneliness i think i guess of course
he's telling me everything she want to
hear that she probably haven't heard in
years and of course it's
a celebrity in my heart i believe it's
him he promised me a future with him so
that's what i'm looking forward to
she's being scammed and used at some
point somebody's gonna notice that 50
80 000 is gone from here and and where
did it go
sometimes it can be months before these
things are found out
so what's happening here is that this
fake jason mamoa
is sending her money oh he's sending
he's sending her money into her account
it's like money laundering
what happened here so he's using her
account like like to move the money
through
because then she's transferring it to a
different you don't have hair though
that's true oh you're jason she's joe
larping i'm jason mobile if joe had hair
he'd probably do something like that
oh she was like listen i've seen all his
bits and pieces and we've been together
for a while
i didn't get that he was sending her
money yeah he's sending her the money
and so she's like moving it to a
different account oh she's oh she's
she's been accomplished
exactly so then that's poor lady stepped
in and was like hey i don't want my mom
getting in trouble like obviously she's
getting scammed but she doesn't believe
me like can someone help
check your parents emails because they
don't know what the hell they're doing
people that want to stay stubborn though
i kind of feel like they kind of deserve
it dude i wish it was actually mamoa
[ __ ] laundry money can you imagine if
it was really
him i see his face i see his body
when she said the body part you know
what they was talking about so yeah so
like they had phone sex
they had the phone she sent it to me
she's telling her son listen here little
[ __ ] i
had none of this in a long time so
you're gonna let me have this jason my
mother
how do you deep fake that body this
guy's [ __ ] pumped over there
what's happening what i'm just saying
maybe it's my mom could just take uh
from the
body down from the body down you take a
picture of some
porn person oh are we saying all people
that
launder money are out of shape are you
saying that all in shape guys are porn
people we're shaming laundry
he could have just got video of other
dudes there's so many ways look at
snapchat filters
[ __ ] i had no hair the other day okay
but what if she's really getting so much
joy
from this interaction she's like let me
stay in the dream world i don't give
away that's what she's saying in my
heart
in my heart i know she's like let me
move money
i know well the the cops they said that
as long as she's not keeping a penny
then she can't actually or i don't know
about can't actually but
it's it's better for her that she's not
keeping yeah because she could still be
an accomplice
depends on what state you're in let's
just be real what state is she
texas but now they're they're watching
her accounts they're watching where the
money's going all the time she's like
i'm 72.
i'll go to jail for this yeah yeah
at night she's like am i going to see
jason
you're you're gonna bail me out maybe
you coming to visit me in jail tell my
stupid-ass son put your name on books
all right
no apparently according to her jason the
fake jason momoa is telling her that
he's planning on leaving
lisa bennett his wife for her
like he has to just put money away into
an account where his wife can't get to
it i hope my confidence is that high one
day
i wanna believe somebody's gonna uh oh i
wanna be her
be her i wanna be i just wanna be that
confident to think i want to be
wooed by a catfish yeah how would that
go i just want to fall in love with a
catfish and just keep it all online
should i make a fake account do you want
to play are we very probably
that'd be pretty cool what does she have
to look like what photo are we going to
use should i use your item should i use
my own photo can you pretend to be you
oh i think so yeah i think they'll be
the best
this is interesting interesting angle
i'm here for it no
yeah i just want you to grow my
mushrooms ooh
i want your mushroom head oh that one
see nicki's gonna pretend to be yeah
so you're gonna take her account and
type her yeah
and then you could pretend to be me and
then we're going to be you're just
typing to yourself
and we both get to read the conversation
you have with yourself that would be
really interesting she's just making a
fanfic
i got a log for you to buy oh i can't
wait
uh i can't wait to receive your logs you
seem like a fun guy
that was a fun that was a fun plan
i want to buy it i want to prune your
log oh no you probably should that would
be really gross i hope that right it
seems like a fun guy i think i'm really
cool
i talk i talk to catfishes knowing that
they're catfishes
for a long time have you guys ever have
either one of you been catfish before
no no and if they use puns i'm blocking
them right away yeah
oh man i would fall in love oh my gosh
you like puns
yeah they're fun no my catfish likes my
other catfish's pun
[Laughter]
i've never been single though either
really you've never been single not for
long anyway that's true
and i can't keep you on the market
what's the longest you've been single
uh i was single for like nine days
before i got with nikki nine
day oh wait swoop i've been consistently
in a relationship
for 11 years now it's not even a 90 day
feeling you accumulate
all the single time since you started
dating how much time has that been i
can't math like that
like a year yeah but like like a year i
beat you then what what
what's what do you got mine is only like
two months i think i
i think it was if you added all the way
since you were 12. that was 16
to now i've only been single for two
months oh my god
that's crazy i think yeah but i don't
[ __ ] about it though i love it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you